hi my name is Savannah lira rose and I'm
at BuzzFeed and today I'm reading my
first sighs first CD you ever bought
Hannah Montana and Miley Cyrus do OCD
was like two sides I put it in my cute
little um you know the CD player G&O
girls night out I know that song by
heart I'll support Hannah Montana
forever Hannah Montana forever I put
that wig on
I bought the 3d movie with the glasses
and the wig so I know what I'm about
first time meeting with your co-star uma
Thurman everyone on set like all the
like teen or teen like age cast and
stuff whatever we all got to meet each
other and get to know each other and
talk about our character in the show
more but I didn't get to meet him until
like on the day of like working with her
you know I got to like kind of say hi to
her and kind of introduce myself before
that but it was so like me being small
and feeling like a little mouse that was
scared of like this big like Hollywood
woman but when I actually like got to
work with her and do the scene it like
all melted away she I feel so
comfortable they feel so like not mean
like I feel like she was like oh yeah
we're gonna do this and we're gonna make
something cool and we're both gonna give
like a hundred percent
she has just this super motherly
instinct I think I think she's like a
dragon mom like she's so like she cares
for everybody everyone needs to be safe
and like calm and happy but if you mess
with her she's a dragon and she's gonna
scare you everything's gonna get burned
down and I love her first celebrity
crush
that's revealing that's so revealing
Steve who does have on like okay I had a
huge crush on Prince Zuko after he cut
his hair like after the ponytail and he
got like the cool like shaggy bad-boy
with the bird and then um Michael
Clifford from 5 seconds of summer was
like I don't know I've never been like a
fangirl before like I've never been in a
fandom and then I became a stand
and like 5 foot what is it they get they
would get mad at like 5 sauce like I
haven't been in the fandom for so long I
don't remember if that was the bad one
so don't come for me because my tumblr
was high back in the day just gonna put
that out there
Oh first time meeting your co-star Tony
Goldwyn
Tony's old Tony is like so nice so pure
and like I have like a dark side you
know I like to push people's buttons and
like see what I can like you know be a
little weird try to creep people out and
he wouldn't get creeped out he took it
and like was like I have something
creepier tell you I was like ok this man
is good this man is so friendly and so
nice and the first time I met him was on
set it was like he was sitting right
next to me he sat down like unannounced
Tony Goldwyn plopped down he smelled
amazing I'm so good it was like really
transfixed cuz I was confused I was like
oh yeah oh my god
the first online screening do I reveal
my like scene emo days do I do I give up
that part of myself and like my face
gets exposed here it has X like
lowercase X capital X underscore like
porcelain panic X X dot Oh don't look
for me don't look for me first job first
job I had was a waitress at a cute
little Mexican restaurant I made this
also in the morning and my salsa was mom
my chips were crispy just gonna put that
out there um yeah I was a bomb waitress
it was my first shot oh my god the first
cell phone the first beat me the first
how you gonna reach me um it was like
the sidekick you know like not the cool
I wanted the LLG enemy because it was
cool it came in like cool colors and it
opened up and I like a screen I just had
like the you know I got real good at
texting in class like behind my back
though we go the first scary movie ever
watch was it but it wasn't the first
time I'd ever seen like a horror movie
because the first time I was like I'm
gonna watch one no absolutely terrified
I was petrified because he can do like
this weird laugh where he would like
hold like just the bottom of his jaw and
like the top of his head would move
sometimes and it was it was too much and
it really did start a phobia so Stephen
King hit me up first date you guys won't
know about the most romantic first day
of my life I was rejected we're trying
to go to the carnival
he said no we broke up that was my first
date uh yeah it wasn't very cute you
know I come from like a small town and
this is the most awkward thing ever hey
everybody I'm verified in sitting
outside snow stuff so moany person like
my first kiss I was at a rave actually I
was like 14 I'd snuck into the rain
it was Skrillex and ASAP Ferg's I'm
absolutely in love with both of them at
the time this is like when Skrillex was
still doing dubstep not to be like shady
but and my first kiss was like just in
the middle of like all of the fun of
being I'm such a raver and like I think
we traded candy I think it was the
cheesiest most beautiful little first
kiss I could have ever had and I
remember his name cuz it was just like a
badass name I'm not gonna say it sounds
like Ezra Miller so thank you so much
BuzzFeed
this has been so much fun I am sivanna
Leo rose and make sure to watch chambers
April 26 on Netflix wait can I do my
Sailor Moon wait wait ready for this
[Music]